يبدو ان هناك من كان يعد صواريخ
كيف فقط نقرب للمشاهد لا يحدث عاده عندما
ياتي صاروخ في الاجواء اتجاه الاراضي
الاسرائيليه يتم اعتراضه على الاقل
بصاروخين اثنين من بطاريه القبه الحديديه
فاذا كان الحديث عن 25 صاروخا حوالي 50
صاروخا جرى اطلاقها عمليا من بطاريات
القبه الحديديه فعل الانذار 37 مره في
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه هذا خلق البلبله
ربما في الاحصاء الاولي 100 صاروخ خمسين
او خمسين صاروخ وما الى ذلك من هذه
الاحصائيات حاليا العدد شبه النهائي هو
بانه اطلق اطلقت اطلق عفوا خمسه وعشرون
صاروخا من جنوب لبنان تجاه المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه كان هناك اصابه يعني منشئه
تزويد الوقود في احدى المستوط اصابه طفيفه
ايضا لاسرائيلي من جراء سقوط
شظيه من صاروخ بالقرب منه عمليا فقط من
يتواجد في المستوطنات الحدوديه طلب منه
البقاء بالقرب من مكان امن لكن علينا ان
نشير ايضا الى ان التوقيت اطلاق الصواريخ
وتوقيت بحد ذاته لافت لان عمليا معظم
الاسرائيليين يتواجدون اليوم في اجازه في
اجازه عيد الفصح اول ايام عيد الفصح
اليهودي يتواجدون بشكل كبير جدا في
المستوطنات الشماليه الحدوديه